[Music]
there was an expanding restaurant empire
in the Midwest that is about far more
than food it aims to tackle one of the
nation's biggest problems convicts
getting out of prison and then going
right back in the story of Edwin's
begins with its founder a man who was
given a second chance and then dedicated
his life to making sure others got one
too
it is the latest story in our series who
we are
who's that Berger tonight guys I got it
at edwin's restaurant in Cleveland you
can start rockin the only thing more
important than turning out the finest
food and wine is turning around the
lives of its employees did you order
your I take a look and see what you
branded Christos key is the man in
charge is sit back enjoy two decades ago
he was a boy in trouble you were dealing
drugs mm-hmm how old 18 what happened
well we got caught up in a little thing
and police came we all left he took off
took off
christos he found himself in front of a
forgiving judge the charge that carry
was about five to ten years in prison
why didn't he do that well I think
there's two reasons color my skin and
the grace of God given probation instead
of hard time Christos key caught on
inside a kitchen in his hometown of
Detroit trained at the Culinary
Institute of America and was soon
working at top French restaurants in
Paris and New York but the second chance
he got was always in the back of his
mind so he came up with a plan the goal
is to have the best French restaurants
in the world the best French restaurant
in the world in Cleveland yeah Ohio why
here I just looked at where the worst
high school graduation rate was and
Cleveland Ohio happened to be the number
two city in the country where people in
high school didn't graduate so I figure
that's the place that it's neither you
went to where you saw the situation
being the worst and said I'm gonna make
the best makes sense one term like this
everyone who trains at edwin's
short for education wins has had some
sort of run-in with the law and then he
spent years in prison so
truant it's the school it's the the
Institute yeah Chris dusky wants to
redirect their lives with a restaurant
bootcamp a six-month program that
provides housing a library donated
clothes even a small farm this is a
brute so it's gonna have very very
little sugar students take classes in a
wide range of topics including the art
of champagne tasting and opening twist
the cork one way the bottle the other
one the days are long noon until
midnight and only thirty percent of
students make it through when you talk
to someone either in prison or just out
of prison and you tell them that you
want to train them to become a French
chef what's the usual reaction I think
it's twofold I think it's one I have no
idea what you're talking about can't say
that on TV yeah I have no idea what
you're talking about
and the other thing is if you give me
sand I'll drink it just give me an
opportunity I'll take it because that
opportunity hasn't been there in the
past what's your goal long term change
the face of reentry change the face of
real change the face rich change that
perception of someone coming out of
prison or jail or a bad hard time or
addiction you're not a lost soul you're
you're redeemable of course yeah of
course malar edema you redeem and kick
some ass too so now we get into
something little bit more intimate
that's fish all right I mean it's me of
all the things that cook I have two
passions of cooking I mean cooking in
general but risotto and fish Christos
Key also trains those still doing time
inside 13 ohio prisons including here at
Grafton Correctional Institution these
men will be out soon and no one wants
them to reoffending on the bone man you
guys did a great job Chris now ski says
they need skills the class we watched is
full of hardcore convicts you're too
forceful if you got to push that hard
you're doing so you're cutting through
bone sentences for murder kidnapping
armed robbery and more let's find the
sharpest blade steal it and we'll go to
today they're learning to fillet salmon
you've got guys who have been convicted
of some pretty horrendous crimes with
large very sharp knives does that
concern you at all this is the most n
piece I feel all week it's really the
safest place you could ever be inside of
prison with inmates with sharp knives
it's the safest place you can be know in
12 inches I'm serious
you know focused and dedicated their
life to to call any arts to improving to
fulfilling potential there's no greater
space to be in with another human being
dear Olympic is nearing the end of a
decade-long sentence for drug
trafficking and weapons charges you know
what they say right you get out what you
put in so I guess you put in the work
you reap the reward are you ready to put
in the work in the right in the right
way sure for sure
I've had enough that we've had enough
nine years I can walk the strain there I
can do the right thing and you think
these classes help you get this gives me
a purpose
Christoph's Keys nonprofit program is
funded by his main restaurants and
private donations he says he won't take
any government money what do you want
people to take from the idea of Edwin's
well it is hope this thing is supported
by like seven year olds who've given a
for dollars their allowance four dollars
in a ziploc bag of coin and the next day
it's a half million dollar check so from
the very least of us the very most of us
it works and without that it doesn't
work so the hero here is a community the
community of people staffing this the
community people supporting it
seven-year-old you can't say that on TV
but it is sweet it is yes seven years
old yes she believes that someone is
there's a second chance right pretty
sweet because people do deserve a second
chance and and when you watch anything
that idea behind recidivism it's got to
give people a purpose you have to give
them education if they didn't have it
you have to give them a skill so that
there is a job to go to in the chance
with a job it's a huge problem so long
term but ten years out the DOJ says up
to eighty three percent of people who
leave prison end up right back in Edwin
says their number with their graduates
so far 350 is one point four percent so
something is working there so there's
the restaurant there's the pizzeria he
has a butcher shop now and opening a
bakery as well
I'm just so floored by the fact that
this decision on the part of the judge
not only changed the trajectory of his
life but now he is changing the
trajectories potentially of all these
other lives it is amazing what one
person can do I know where I'm right in
Cleveland there you go